you know I always think about that
picture where it looks like two people
kissing or like a glass of champagne
like I'm you know like the flute I'm so
fascinated by perspective like adversity
either crumbles you or becomes
foundational to your success you got
your perspective
[Music]
[Applause]
well I'll also tell you this this is
something just at a much higher level
you find yourself and change positions
because life is only changed
there is no it stops like there is only
there's only one constant that things
are always changing and you know you you
may perceive them as not changing but
they're changing things are moving at
all times
my grandmother is crying because of your
lack of subscribing to my youtube
channel
can't you just subscribe
[Applause]
[Music]
hi my name is Matthew Bella I directed
the Netflix documentary minimalism I'm
curious for people who are trying to
find meaning in life to live a
meaningful life what would you say I
think a couple things you know this it's
a very heavy question I think people
first of all have to give a lot more
thought to the environment and the
parents that raised them there's a lot
of answers in there like a lot so that's
interesting to me that's just one
heartache I believe one of the great
ways to mix things up is what you listen
to and who you surround yourself with I
would I'm unbelievably passionate about
people finding more optimistic practical
friends and I and I think optimism gets
can get can slide into delusion which is
why I say optimistic Oprah chol you know
it's funny as you were talking about
middle ism like I didn't it it's so
interesting that you're the first person
ever say it to me that I can recall and
it feels very real to me like I don't
have outside things kind of driving me
and that's what leads me to a lot of
happiness and so I would say auditing
your circle like if somebody wants to
meet a minute to life living a
meaningful life leave just get happier I
think the people that you spend your
time with is a big one the amount of
people listening right now who've got a
mother who's super pessimistic and
cynical but they love their mother and
they don't realize that cutting down
their time from seven hours a week of
engagement with their mother to two and
adding like going out of their way to
seeing the person that's always smiling
in the office and trying to spark up a
friendship and become friends with that
person and cutting up that seven hours a
week from mom too
- - mom maybe 30 minutes with that
person and maybe reallocating the other
hours to themselves or other things is a
massive deal
it's a massive deal like there's only
offense and defense there's only the
force in the dark side right and I think
that um right now people are a lot of
people are choosing to be driven by fear
and negativity without realizing it and
so if you're listening right now my
biggest thing is start leaning into a
little bit more of optimism and
positivity I think where it overcorrects
is when it goes into delusion and that's
when you start craving entitlement and
that is the tightrope that I've been
talking about thinking about watching
and it's I create entitlement a lot of
times because I like positivity and it
took me a little while maybe 20 or 30
years 20 years of operating and managing
and parenting and being like okay I
think I can see this but I'm not but I'm
a product of not I kind of fell into
customizing all by accident
my cousin asked me if I could fix his
shoes did more research saw that art was
being done on shoes and that's how I got
to where I'm at today
like the consumerization of like America
and like what people deem a success is
something I've been thinking about a ton
like a it's super on my mind like there
was no reason for you to having to go
broke again yeah just you bought dumb
[ __ ] because that's the culture yeah I
was young yes I was seeing people do it
and I totally understand I wasn't
worried about the next step of course no
but I feel like everything that I've
gone through today has been very
valuable in my success now only because
you've been able to build on top of it
like adversity either crumbles you or
becomes foundational to your success I
you know I always think about that
picture where it looks like two people
kissing or like a glass of champagne
like I'm you know like the flute I'm so
fascinated by perspective the amount of
people who decide in your situation
when you hurt your back that's see see
it was just about to get good but God
took it away from me and just give up is
a lot I mean that and then people who
like go into a wheelchair because
they're paralyzed and decide that's the
platform that they're gonna use to like
change the world
I'm just so fast about perspective there
were literally people today worldstar
picked up a clip that I posted about me
doing a garage sale flip how much of
cars oh sorry
25 cars it's perfect yes thank you so
much man wish you well take care of sup
destroyed their faces it's at least a
honda and literally people are like
going in there yeah and people going in
there flaming me and saying you're
ripping people off and I'm fascinated by
perspective like I'm just fascinated by
people's ability to deploy cynicism okay
I'm 17 right now out in LA in turn it
for them I know my value how do I make
other people see it beyond the monetary
gain if there is none you just ask and
you don't dwell on somebody not seeing
it it just becomes a matter of time and
if you don't feel like somebody's paying
you or seeing the value you just find
the next person to have the conversation
with you know yeah alright you can't
force somebody that you want to see
something to see something you either
decide to stay the course and give a
discount and however you've defined the
discount cuz you want to do it for that
person like if I want my Tyson to think
I'm the coolest then I can work for him
for four even five years until he does
or I could be like [ __ ] you Mike Tyson
I'm gonna work for Evander Holyfield
got it yeah it was
[Music]
my name is Joey eco and I live in LA I
make music how you doing okay what's
been going on it seems like things are
going well I'm where you don't make
music in English because it naturally
happens that way or thoughtfully you
wanted to go about it that way got it
yeah yeah like like if you go into booth
or if you like go musical does it like
like you think in Spanish do we still
want to ask you that right away was it's
kind of like I think a lot of the
reasons some of my content goes viral is
cuz I think in Russian and there's a lot
of rumors yeah I was born in Russia yeah
in Belarus specifically and I think in
Russian and so a lot of sayings and
things I think are trans I'm translating
them from a Russian standpoint to
English and they haven't been said that
way in English even though they're
things that you know like my favorite
saying that something my grandma used to
say was you can't put your ass on two
toilets which was basically like don't
get stretched thin yeah so like when I
like sometimes make content I'll so I
could say that and I was like that's
insane
but they just had never heard that in
that it's all the same [ __ ] that like
all these sayings in every language are
the same like trying to make the same
point but the analogies are different
and so I think a lot of my analogies are
unique because I'm not well-read and
because I think in Russian and so what
as I've been listening to your stuff and
then like and then just like hearing you
talk right now and I'm like huh I wonder
if she when she's creative thinks in
Spanish and that's why that happens I
mean
opportunity yeah yeah I get it so I'm
basically at this point in my everything
I've made I've just scrapped scrapped
just like I'm my own pocket like yep yep
work save invest in your career exactly
but so I'm just like in that like we're
talking to a couple of labels but like
that hasn't happened and we're taking
our time with that and I want to put
some music out exactly you want leverage
exactly the longer I wait the more
leverage 100% that's well God well it
God willing something gets crazy and
pops you've got all you got much more
leverage I understand that is the model
yeah that's the beauty of tonight you
feel it yep and you know what and you
know what's funny like a lot of times we
were like I know my worth you're being
actually more thoughtful than that
you're putting yourself in a position to
allow the market to establish your worth
yeah everybody knows they're worth the
amount of people there's millions of
people running around saying I know my
worth and never do anything because the
market doesn't give them the leverage to
create worth what I like about what
you're doing is you're not sitting in
your room ideologically saying I know my
worth you're putting in work to get
money to put yourself in a position
you're doing it the right way
no it's real I mean it no I mean it I
mean it like I think I know my worth
it's like when people always say look
I'm not willing to work for free I know
my worth and I'm like you you go like
you have cute you're winning you're
building a foundation on humility you're
actually working and I'm sure you know
I'm not sure but I assume you need to
have a job that gives you flexibility so
you're probably not making a billion
dollars a year exactly yep and so like I
just I just wish more youngsters would
follow your blueprint people are just
not willing to eat [ __ ] and like it's
just entitlement everybody just decided
they're the best rapper in the world
and they just leave comments on rappers
instagrams and be like you haven't heard
me yet I'm the best cool show me of
course that's like like it's caught it's
called SoundCloud and Spotify like you
have distribution yeah if you're so good
show me
everyone's talking good for you
it's exactly right that's the way to do
it every single artist in the world
should build leverage I taught myself
photography in 2007 people started
hiring me so much so that by 2008 I was
traveling the world is such a pleasure
hello we actually met in May of 2017
at the four DS event I have to say thank
you because that event changed my life
how so you inspired me to start
something new in my business and a
couple months later I launched a brand
new product in your business social
curator which is that monthly system to
get membership and we provide 30
lifestyle photos 30 caption templates to
help people talk about their business
without selling you know and then an
action plan in a community and within 12
months we created a seven-figure revenue
stream in the business so somebody took
what we learned started applying it and
I just have to say thank you because
it's not about the business like you
empowered me to be me so thank you it's
not it's an awesome that makes me I if
that's all I get to say to you like it's
totally worth it so we currently have
six thousand members and we're on trend
to reach 10,000 by the end of 2018 and
so we have a community and I asked the
community hey what would you guys like
to see next and the thing that we heard
of the most is that people want to
social curator app because I can see if
they want to remove the friction from
taking the resources that we provide for
them and pushing it to their social
platforms and then things get a little
bit tricky because when I started asking
what features do you find the most
valuable in an app if you were to create
one the number one thing was we want to
organize plan and
all our posts but we want to use these
resources if I were to create an app
that service their primary demands or
requests it would put me squarely in the
organizational planning app space which
is a totally different business model
than what I currently have so my
question to you is if you were me would
you create the app or would you like
triple down on the investment that the
time and the cost to create an app
that's a slightly different business
model that we currently have and puts us
squarely in a different type of app
space um my first read is I'd probably
consider to quadruple down on what's
already working and go from 6,000 to
60,000 and use that leverage of even
6,000 to probably JV with an organizing
app that creates some sort of
relationship I'm I think that people
need to be thoughtful about what they're
good at and then be even more thoughtful
about what doesn't come as natural or
what they may not be as interested in I
would say in parrot based on that I
would say consider finding an app
partner that already does what you're
thinking about building and say to them
you call up Charlie and say hey Charlie
I'm 6,000 [ __ ] people paying me and
they want this I don't necessarily want
to do it how's your business going you
don't know what's out there do you know
many apps I'll give you one I would look
at the bottom 50 apps in the space I'll
tell you why they've might have they
might have 30 you know any app guys and
girls are out there that makes 600 apps
and this is one of them that they made
and they actually built a really good
product but they're focused on the one
that popped and you can like swoop up
and take the technology for five
thousand bucks you have to explore I
think you should look at the bottom 50
apps I have a funny yeah I have a funny
feeling think about it right you might
be able to like if you think about it's
about you know you you look at top 10
right you go to they have leverage
because there are top 10 for reason you
go to number 83 number 83 might be a
better app than top 10
the person's just not working it I'm
unbelievably passionate about people
finding more optimistic practical
friends I'm fascinated by perspective
like I'm just fascinated by people's
ability to deploy cynicism and so like I
just I just wish more youngsters would
follow your brain
[Music]